and welcome to this special edition of
Hannity now tonight for the full hour
Fox News correspondent our friend
Benjamin Hall he's going to tell us his
courageous Story of Survival
perseverance and it's going to be in his
own words now exactly one year ago in
March of 2022 while Benjamin Hall was on
assignment in key covering the outbreak
of the war Vladimir Putin was attempting
to encircle Ukraine's capital city of
Kiev with a series of brutal attacks and
Benjamin Hall was working around the
clock to bring all of us real-time
information on the ground
here with more on the ground he's in
Kiev tonight the capital of Ukraine
Fox's own Benjamin Hall Benjamin what's
going on tonight
what we've seen is it's a continuation
if not an escalation of what we've seen
over the last week increasing number of
attacks on civilian areas an inability
to get humanitarian Aid into these
surrounded cities and an inability for
people to get out of them
then just a few days later on March the
14th Hall was on a fact-finding mission
on the outskirts of Ukraine with two
other journalists Pierre and Sasha when
they were viciously attacked by Russian
forces now Pierre and Sasha they were
killed and Hall was left fighting for
his life here's Jennifer Griffin
and Brett a word about our colleagues
Pierre Sasha and Ben Hall tonight the
loss and pain we feel is enormous but if
ever there were a time that the world
needed journalists reporters risking
their lives to tell these stories to
tell the truth it's now without a free
press the autocrats win we will redouble
our efforts to honor these colleagues
and all reporters In Harm's Way tonight
and Jennifer worked endlessly tirelessly
to help Benjamin and get him to safety
now in the hours days and weeks and
months that followed Benjamin fought for
his life and he did it with such a
positive attitude I've had the honor of
speaking with Ben throughout his
recovery and his courage in the face of
what is Unthinkable adversity is an
inspiration personally to me and to so
many others he has a new book I urge you
to read it saved a war reporter's
mission to make it home it is out March
the 14th and by the way it is a must
read I recently sat down with Benjamin
Hall in New York here is part one of
this interview
Benjamin Hall saved a war reporter's
mission to make it home my friend
welcome home thank you great to see you
thank you pleasure to be here you talk
about the term of War correspondent
you've been all over the world
unfortunately there's been many
conflicts and you've been you've you
were at the uh Syrian Civil War you were
mosul in Iraq you were in Kabul in in
Afghanistan uh during wartime Mogadishu
and then of course Ukraine
you're in warzos that's your job it's so
hard you see I can only imagine the
things that you've seen over the year
the years and every place you've been to
tell us about that
yeah it's a job that you can both love
and both hate
you hate it because you see some of the
horrible things most horrible things
families losing everything homes schools
being demolished children who have
nothing you have to love it too you have
to understand why you're doing it and
the importance of it you've got to
understand that those stories as you
tell them to other people really have
influence and I think we need to know
these stories and so
it's been hard and it's a job that once
you start once you love it it's very
difficult to do anything else because
there are very few other jobs that
fill you with such perhaps Pride
and necessity to do it so now I've I've
done all the wars and I feel when a war
breaks out you've got to be there to
cover it and it's important to our
viewers and it's dangerous work and
maybe did you ever imagine what happened
to you what happened did you did those
thoughts go through your head
yeah I mean it's interesting I was
surrounded by colleagues who were
injured seven or eight who died over the
years and so I knew it could happen I've
seen it happen but did I ever think it
would happen to me
no I I'm not sure I did I knew the risks
I knew it could happen but I think there
has to be a little element inside you
that has to believe it won't and so you
make every precaution and take every
precaution you can before you go in
there and you're aware of the risks but
you can't let it Cloud your judgment you
can't let it distract you when you're
working because if that clouds your mind
you won't do your job as well so you
think about it beforehand but when you
go in
you focus on the job and the work and
the people you're talking to and you
don't let any fear fill your mind you
talk about your injuries let's talk
about that day
and you were with Pierre your cameraman
who didn't make it out alive and a
journalist was there as well who didn't
make it out alive
and let's talk about the moment that
changed your life forever and and what
you remember about it you talk about
going black and then you tell a pretty
miraculous story about
getting your Consciousness back let's
let's talk about that moment that day
yeah I mean um well firstly I was I was
saved that day we were out we were
filming in an abandoned Village just
outside Kiev the Russians had almost
surrounded the city and the idea was
they would take it in the next few days
we actually ironically weren't planning
on going up to the front lines we were
filming these areas that had been
totally demolished and we saw schools
that have been hit churches that had
been hit and we filmed this all
ourselves
and as we'd finished we were driving
back towards the capital city of Kiev
hadn't seen anyone in a long time and we
slowed down an abandoned checkpoint and
I don't know where the first missile
came out of nowhere
man's about 30 feet in front of us
immediately Pierre shouts reverse the
car reverse the car there were two
ukrainians driving as well and five of
us in the car
got stuck we couldn't go back and Pierre
shouted get out of the car everyone get
out of the car and the next second the
second Bond hits right in front of the
left of the car
and that one I went black
and I I was in a dark place
I couldn't feel or see
um and I'd taken some shrapnel in the
eye and I the matchboxized shraple in my
in my neck and I was I was out I was out
dead
and then I saw my my daughter out of
nowhere into this Blackness right in
front of me came my daughter honor
and she said to me
Daddy
you've got to get out of the car
real as if she was in front of me I
don't know where she came to me and I
came to and I opened up my eyes and my
instinct took me towards the car door
and I scrambled I pulled myself out and
I got out of the car and the third bomb
hit the car itself right after that next
thing I know I wake up it's thrown me
away I'm on fire my right leg is gone I
roll around I try to put that then you
you had lost your foot of that I'd lost
a foot um the foot had gone ironically I
didn't notice it at the time and then
your eye is injured and and everybody's
bleeding everywhere that took pieces out
of my of my skull outer my left hand
which has been put back together was all
torn up the thumb hanging off
so um I was lying there
lying there and Pierre was still alive
at this point
and Pierre immediately said don't move
Russian drones Russian drones
and so I'm lying there in this Barren
landscape
trying not to move trying to think of
what we can do looking at my injuries
realizing how badly injured I am
and I get my cell phone out and no
reception can't get hold of hold of
anyone no one knew where we were we'd be
moving around a little bit
and so I actually had my cell phone out
and the first thought I was I will
record what I'm seeing and I actually
stopped and I took a picture of my leg
and some of my injuries and I
immediately thought well
my children can't see this if I don't
come home that can't be the last picture
that perhaps they see so I was sitting
there and I deleted them immediately
but we lay there for a while longer
and uh Pierre again who was lying about
five feet away from me or so
just lying there
said the Russians the Russians
and after a while a car came past it was
up on this hit a ridge just by me I
shouted a car a car car and I started
trying to wave at it way better trying
to get attention it didn't see me and
Pierre said it's the Russians it's the
Russians
and I said uh it doesn't matter I'm so
badly injured I've got to go and I
remember thinking it doesn't matter
about my injuries I'm going home I will
do whatever it takes right now I will
drag myself home pull myself and I
started pulling myself along the ground
dragging myself up the hill
and that same car a little while later
took a wrong turning down the road
turned around and it came back and by
that point I was a little bit higher up
and I had my hand full of dirt and
stones and I was waving and I threw it
at the car and they saw me and they
stopped
ran out and grabbed hold of me
they dragged you dragged me that was the
first time I felt real pain amazingly I
was so sort of the adrenaline was
pumping through me at first and I could
see the injuries but I wasn't feeling
the pain and as soon as I was dragged it
on the ground and the burns and the skin
a lot of that just came off there and
that was the point that I suddenly felt
the real pain and I was thrown into the
back of this van worse pain you've ever
felt by far in your life that say and
then when I was evacuated as well and
there were no pain meds as well and um
it sends you to a new place an awful
place but somewhere that you have to
find a way through
and then I was the last thing I remember
I found an ambulance at a checkpoint the
nearest checkpoint that had people I
remember getting an injection
and that was the end of that part
and then the next thing I know I wake up
I'm in this Hospital
and I don't know where I am and I look
around me and I assume I'm in Russia all
I know is that we were saying Russians
the car was Russian
this point I've got bars coming out of
my leg I can't move very badly injured
but again I'm thinking I'm in Russia how
do I get out I've got to find a way out
I'm going to escape here
someone came into the room with my state
department press card I'd been working
there and he was holding it out menu
chatting who are you who are you
and the man opposite this other patient
in the bed was moving and his sheep
started to rise so I assumed he had a
gun pointed at me so I'm in the Spy
world and I think that I'm I'm being
held what can I do how can I get out
and into the room what this American
rich jadick and didn't know him at the
time he looked down at me and he said
hey Ben
you want to get out of here
I said absolutely let's go whatever it
takes let's go
and I said by the way that guy's rushing
and he's got a gun which of course
wasn't the truth at all but that was the
time that I came into the hands of save
our allies and the incredible team that
came in to get me and what they did to
get me on short notice uh after Jen
Griffin our Pentagon reporter reached
out to them spoke to Sarah Verrado who
set them up this is the same group who
got many people out of Afghanistan when
it fell they're still getting people out
of Afghanistan they put together this
team former soldiers Former Intelligence
who came right in straight away from
Poland they bought two battered up old
ambulances and they broke right into
Kiev as the shells were falling they
came in because they knew another
American was stuck in there and that was
me and they were going to risk their own
lives to get one American home and one
of them had a great friend uh
who died in Afghanistan meaning they'd
served all in Afghanistan and one of
them had watched a friend of his Ben die
and his friend Ben had daughters and he
said I lost my last friend Ben who had
daughters at home I'm not gonna lose
another one Whatever It Takes we'll go
in and get in there
and then I was taken into the hands of
this incredible group of people and they
saved my life then and there let me let
me go back a little bit
and I want to talk a little more about
your daughter
so everything goes black there's
nothingness in a sense you have no idea
what had happened
and you you feel you see the presence of
your daughter
right there in front of you yeah you
mentioned in the book that you believe
in God yeah do you believe that that was
God sending your daughter to say daddy
wake up absolutely my family are angels
they were sent to me and I know I was
saved that day as well and uh when I saw
her it was an incredible piece as well
it was blacked out but it was
quiet there was it wasn't rushed it
wasn't
as fearful she came to me in this
Blackness and this peace though and said
Dad you've got to get out of the car
your daughter's name is Honor his honor
but I think it was all three of my
daughters it was honor it was Iris it
was hero they came together to me that
day
but if I had been an inch in any
direction I'd be dead I was sitting in
the middle seat of this little car or
the back row the other four people died
and if I had been any anywhere else I'd
have been blind in both eyes I would
have suffered serious head injuries and
somehow I came out of this and I came
out of this I think in an incredible way
I feel I came out of it with my mind
intact my will intact my optimism intact
My Hope intact and I think that God gave
me that and my family gave me that and
they brought me back and if I can't can
do just one thing it's to pass that on
to others know that if if you try hard
you work hard if you believe in the
right things you can get through
absolutely anything
my daughters who came to me that day hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else